I think off of the pure fact that this
episode is primarily a flashback will be
people's least favorite episode of the
season to me it started out as my least
favorite after finishing it and the more
I think about it the more the episode
grows on me can it be better yes and
I'll go over two main aspects in a
second that bothered me and I think
could have increased the quality of the
episode if they were fixed one of those
main complaints is not the notion of any
of this being filler because we are
doing a major exploration of one of our
main characters that further flushes
them out and brings even more context to
the soul being of Ellie's character we
see the environment she grew up in which
explains her more tough Persona we see
the authoritative figures that hold
power over her life that fuels her
rebellious nature and we see her most
prize and close relationship fall to
ruins which explains why she's so afraid
of losing Joel if you think about it the
writing in this episode is Brilliance
Neil druckman did an outstanding job
adapting the DLC from the first game
into this episode despite right there
being no current plot progression the
episode is still very efficient on a
scene to scene basis as a developing
Ellie more that's why I don't understand
why people are calling this episode
filler it feels like they're just
looking at it from the perspective of
solely plot progression as if these
characters are only an icon on a board
game moving from point A to B if
anything this episode is the opposite of
filler because it focuses on a main
character to prove this you could
technically sandwich these scenes in the
middle of episode 1 when we do the
20-year time Jump because that would be
where it mostly lines up in the timeline
from there it would act as a great
character introduction for Ellie and
both Joel and Ellie's past would be
flesh out at that point now I'm not
arguing this should be the case and I
think the flashback episode is fine
where it is but it adds to the story
because it deals with one of our main
characters with this same logic and if
you think Ellie's flashback is filler
then by definition that would make Joel
starting point filler too you may be
thinking that I'm reaching here but in
terms of structure for a season one if
you had Joel's flashback in this episode
as an example then it also wouldn't
progress the current plots however
Joel's starting point is important for
the show because of how much character
progression and context we learn about
him and that's why I think Ellie's
flashback is almost as equally important
throughout the show we can pick up on
details about what happened to Ellie and
why she's the way she is and that might
be your reasoning as to why we don't
need this flashback but the same can be
said about Joel like with Ellie slowly
learning that Joel had a daughter before
the outbreak so overall my point is that
Ellie's flashback may seem more like
filler because of where it lies within
the story and in reality it's not
because of how much it adds to her
character sorry for that tangent I feel
like I needed to fully explain that from
how many people I've seen complaining
about this so moving away from the
filler Hot Topic let's go into the
episode strengths by far the best aspect
to me is the duo of Ellie and Riley they
were riveting in basically every scene
they had together in turn exploring the
five wonders of the mall was
surprisingly wholesome like I didn't
think an escalator could make anyone
this happy so the fact that Ellie is
this blown away is hilarious the episode
overall harnesses The Fish Out of Water
aspect really well and every area of the
mall they spend time in feels perfectly
utilized especially the stores because
it brings up the practicality of living
in an apocalypse and we can see the
different outlandish things we use in
our society that are no longer relevant
in theirs like soap obviously who the
hell uses that but going back to Ellie
and Riley the acting for both of them
was outstanding in this episode I loved
all the subtle details having to do with
Ellie being attracted to Riley some
examples include having Riley turn
around when Ellie was changing clothes
you're so weird about that Ellie asking
Riley if the reason she joined the
fireflies was because of her boyfriend
but set under the guise of a joke to
mask her intentions so what happened you
started dating some Firefly dude and was
like us
well I think I'll be a terrorist Ellie
being giddy that Riley did all of this
for her Ellie fixing her hair in the
mirror and then a lot of other minor
moments of Ellie gazing at Riley with so
much joy picking up on all this is so
much fun and to me is the definition of
great writing and acting the marriage
between these two aspects of the show
and how well they synergize together
makes me sad that this episode is
getting downplayed so much because it
gets even better from here when they get
bit by the infected and they have to
confront the crushing reality that the
love they just discovered between each
other is over that's extremely
heartbreaking and again the actors here
nail the sorrow in Rage that comes along
with this terrible reality Bella Ramsay
is flat out amazing and she is giving a
performance of a lifetime at such an
early age it makes me excited to see her
in the future as she grows even further
as an actor although she's already at a
point where she's better than most
actors who are even older than her going
into another aspect that I loved was the
production design it's been spectacular
throughout the show but seeing a rundown
mall with so much detail in every square
inch was astounding to see every surface
withering away the flickering lights the
vegetation even making its way into this
space the amount of sugar on the ground
we can hear them walk on and then this
being contrasted with more pristine
areas that people don't care about like
the arcade makes their inclusion even
more exciting it adds to this notion of
them stepping into this world before the
outbreak and they get to live a slice of
Life detached from all the dog [__] they
have to deal with every day it's
beautiful happy loud bright fun and
everything about the space is an under
contradiction about any other aspect
previously set up in this world making
it that much more important to these
characters and it even feels surreal I
think experiencing this moment at this
point in the story makes it so
satisfying from how treacherous and
devoid of Happiness Joel and Ellie's
Journey has been these small happy
moments are the reminder of how great
life can be and seeing these characters
live through them is special because of
how much they have to overcome overall
the five Wonders of the World sequence
has an infectious Aura of Happiness tied
to it and I absolutely loved it even
adding in the song Take On Me was a
great Touch Too a couple of other minor
things I loved about this episode were
the ways in which Ellie bonding with
Riley were shot and how they set up the
Rogue infected in the mall most of the
cinematography involving Ellie being
visually in love with Riley were
generally lit with warm colors it gives
off this feeling of safety and happiness
and it splashes onto the screen with so
much Vibrance especially in comparison
to the rest of what the show looks like
like the arcade scene being washed out
in pink in particular I feel like was
visual foreshadowing of their romance
then I think it was genius setting up
the single infected in the mall
relatively early because it creates a
lot of suspense it's kind of like the
Hitchcock method of showing a bomb under
a table and then continuing on with the
dialogue scene because once they show
that infected you know he's going to
come back and you're left with his
feeling of oncoming Doom that can't be
avoided so again it's sad to see this
episode getting hated on from how much
fun it ended up being unless the people
are also mad about Ellie being gay like
Bill and Frank and if that's the case
then oh boy they're just a lost cause at
that point then besides all the great
positives there are still a couple
aspects about this episode that bothered
me the first one is Neil druckman not
intercutting enough between the present
and the past to make this episode feel
more productive in the present in terms
of plots I think they should have given
Ellie more to do that could then also
allow more transition points between the
present and the past because currently
all Italy does in the present is search
the house and find something to search
up Joel with if I were writing this I
probably would have included an
objective for Ellie to achieve like
there being a CVS or something across
the street that she has to search and in
there maybe she has to overcome a
clicker on her own which could also be a
mirror between her fighting the infected
in the past but this time maybe she
doesn't fight it and instead outsmarts
it by luring it away with bottles like
in the game or even adding in another
transition point where she confronts the
fact of her being upset that she's been
left alone by Riley to then coming back
to her being scared Joel will do the
same and her frantically searching the
house and finding nothing which then she
has to make a critical choice to put
herself in danger to save Joel by
searching the CVS personally I think
this would alleviate that feeling of
there not being enough time in the
present it would give just enough
progression to be satisfying while also
still being able to tie into the past
that and if I had to choose an episode
to be over an hour long then I'd
probably choose this one because another
issue I had was that the ending felt
abrupt I thought we were going to get a
scene where Ellie and Riley spend the
night in the mall together and then the
next morning we have Ellie waking up to
Riley being infected essentially the
mirror to episode 5. to me it would
Elevate the tragic nature of this whole
scenario and having Ellie need to kill
Riley and seeing her struggle to do so
would be insanely sad seeing her break
down after just killing an infected
Riley from sir survival would be a
harrowing scene to watch to say the
least so I'm surprised that Neil
druckman didn't go there I haven't
played the DLC so I don't know if that
was cut or if that wasn't originally in
there but I would have loved to see that
explored and there's even more they
could have done past that like with the
paranoia of Ellie potentially turning
because as they said in the episode it
could take hours or even days it also
would have been nice to see Marlene
eventually showing up and finding Ellie
in this state that's where I thought
that episode would have ended and it
feels like a missed opportunity overall
to end it so soon just as I was ready to
be rocked and floored emotionally the
episode ended and I couldn't help but
feel disappointed in that moment
regardless though I still find the
episode very enjoyable and one other
minor thing that bugged me was how dark
it was in the beginning when Riley and
Ellie were on the rooftops there was a
moment where they were like there's the
mall that's it it's right there and I
was like huh where it looked like a
black abyss from how dark it was it's
kind of hard to be mad at this scene
though since they need to be sneaking
around at night however it is a
coincidence that I only ever have this
problem occasionally with other HBO
shows like Game of Thrones and House of
the Dragon it might just have to do with
how they color correct the footage but
yeah overall I still like this episode
despite it not having current plot
progression where I drink it in
comparison to the other episodes would
probably be in the lower bracket and
that's mainly because of the fact of how
great they've all been so far so
competition is fierce thank you for
watching and let me know what you
thought about episode 7 of The Last of
Us
thank you